ciao a tutti sono di stare un po troppo
vicino alla videocamera e allo stesso
tempo di non avere il mio solito
background ma di avere un fratello che
passa dietro ho capito che una
continuiamo il problema è che mia madre
ha deciso di rinnovare un pochino caso e
tra le cose ha deciso di infilare un
armadio norma in camera mia distruggendo
via tutto quello che aveva appeso così
perché la nave alla fine io sono dovuto
sottostare alle decisioni di mia madre
perché quando mia madre vuole fare un
qualcosa meglio lasciarglielo fare qui
anno vorrei cambiare la casa non in
senso fisico non voglio trasferirmi
voglio cambiare di mobili voglio di
arredarla ecco guglielmo voglio dire
l'idea di casa non è che la voglio
cambiare la voglio riarredare sai cosa
vuol dire arrivare vuol dire
semplicemente che un attimo sposti due
mobili fai così diventa tutto molto più
carino
gu sto parlando con te vorrei un attimo
ri arredarla cambiarli delle cose se
posso quindi sono da chiederti permesso
posso di arrivarle posso venire qui
posso come madri dire voglio che la mia
casa non sia un porcaio ok mamma fai
quello che vuoi
comunque buon 2011 a tutti quanti so che
un pochino tardi però voluto aspettare
un po di giorni prima di potermi
permettere di fare questo video vi
spiego perché lo capodanno come tutti
quanti i capodanni l'ho passato in
compagnia mangiando giocando facendo
tanti buoni propositi
coraggio ragazzi che manca poco per
quest'anno sono piena di nuovi propositi
anche bella tipo non succederà più chi
atomiche sul cuscino l'origine dormire
come se nulla fosse successo
ma io voglio essere semplicemente
contento non importa quale faccio perché
lo dici oppure deciso di smettere di
mangiare lanifici è sia molto leggero
languorino beh diciamo che non aiuta
nemmeno molto valido
scherzi quale che da quelle cioè gusto
esotico un po piccante 21
15 e soprattutto per il 2011
niente più incontri occasionali con
uomini non scarseggia viene far volare
un paletto che ne dici
[Musica]
il costo è l'ultimo mai
si vabbè diciamo che il mio capodanno
non è andata proprio così e che allo
stesso tempo non abbiamo bevuto sa che
il capodanno devo dirlo è stato
piuttosto divertente perché stavo
compagnia di persone molto simpatica di
quale tengo molto
ammettono c'è stato un momento di
disperazione subito dopo il countdown
finale
una sorta di mezza depressione ecco che
ce ne voglio morire per vita uno schifo
avete tutto col solito quindi non state
queste confidato molto a legna nuovo
anno e so già che se visti ad una
sbirciatina quelli allo scopo in
televisione molto probabilmente il polo
fox di turno mi avrebbe avvisato per
bene
sagittario parla proprio a voi piccoli
saggi tarini armati di akko e con un
corpo da cavallo a voi ne vanti della
prima decade ma questo nuovo vi porterà
a tanta quindi lasciate stare fuggire se
potete ingoiate vi il mestolone di
vostra londra pieno di psicofarmaci
molite del sonno perché è meglio non
avete via di scampo name e lo dico
sinceramente l'anno nuovo ma portato
tantissime novità che ne so
in famiglia in viaggio un secondo fa
e così fatto perché non torni a muovere
i due finiti i semi di gommapiuma stanno
facendo un video molto divertente che
parla di di ragazze fatte da uomini con
la barba di ragazzi un po effemminati e
queste cose che fanno un pochino ridere
le persone che mi seguono su youtube
ma quali sono i the pope abortirlo
altrettanto spettacolari novità il suo
sperimentando dell'amore amore che
cadeva so giocare
non lo so non riesco a pensare al gioco
sarà solo a te non nasceva tesoro non lo
so ma tanta fortuna tentarlo ancora mi
sono stata già così tanto fortunata in
così laverty nella mia vita
cioè io gli ho seriamente a volte penso
che che non meno moreno mai di qualcun
altro come mi sono innamorata di te se
potessi chiedere alle stelle
ora in questo momento e alla notte alla
luna nice matin
questi per vedere a ccc lato se ci vado
meccanicista quattro zampe e nei piumini
importante della scala reale una cosa
importante sono le amicizie quelle vere
quali secolari quelle che durano da
sempre o che ne dici di questi valori
se sei interessato alla prossima domanda
è ma vabbè quest'altra faccio cosa ma
figurati se la sede che ignorante come
sai che prima avevo più video ok va bene
ho perso lo ammetto sono una persona
sportiva che mi sono lieto anzi gli
dissi medi con la gioia nel cuore le
colombe pasquali che mi svolazzano nello
stomaco nell'ammettere che questo 2.000
euro
11 non è cambiato in una sola virgola
2010 tranne che vi auguro che voi stia
andando tutto bene anzi se qualcosa è
cambiato se state riuscendo a ottenere
qualche cosa di importante sentitevi
liberissimi di farmelo sapere qua sotto
anzi sempre un contento dei vostri
successi vivrò come se fossero miei
proprio come un padre con i propri figli